Hello there!
Look, Ms. Coffee Bean is asleep... [sleeping
sounds].
Oooh, isn’t that sweet?
Well, while she sleeps, I wanted to show you
some of my own work.
Ms. Coffee Bean always pressures me to cover
the notorious papers, because those are the
safest bet that will interest YOU and get
HER the clicks... and the views!
Okay, so..., quickly, while she sleeps, I
would like to tell you about my own research
and how that is going.
In a nutshell… you know about the cool idea
to replace the self-attention with the Fourier
Transform?
Yeah, it's not like that.
But you know what, it is honest work and interesting,
nonetheless.
But first, I had to find myself some collaborators.
Or they found me, actually.
You know what?
We found each other!
So this is what we were up to, me and my collaborators…
There was no Ms. Coffee Bean involved, so
better not wake her up, okay …?
Our work is entitled in short “Seeing past
words”; because we are investigating whether
vision and language models really integrate
both the visual and the textual modalities,
as opposed to faking that they are multimodal.
I mean that there is reason to believe, that
models meant for integrating image and text
are actually focusing on language only, exploiting
biases in the textual input.
It was highlighted by previous work.
This question of whether models are mostly
exploiting unimodal signals, has become more
and more interesting since the dawn of transformer-based
vision and language models, which follow the
pre-train and fine-tune paradigm, such as
LXMERT, ViLBERT, and many others.
I’ve talked with Ms. Coffee Bean quite some
times about them on this channel.
Quick reminder: their pre-training includes
multimodal masked language modelling, and
image-sentence alignment, where the goal is
to predict whether an image and a caption
match
or mismatch.
This pre-training on large amounts of paired
image-text data, enables “cross-modal" vision
and language representations that seem "universal",
usable for any task.
Then taking such a pre-trained model and fine-tuning
on downstream tasks like these ones here,
is a good recipe for achieving at least CLOSE-TO
state-of-the-art performance.
So, given the success of these vision and
language models, it is important to ask:
How cross-modal are they really?
We choose to answer this research question
by developing a counting probe.
Why counting?
Because counting nicely combines visual and
textual reasoning.
Counting requires: the detection of object
instances in the image, mapping them to categories,
and also properly aligning the instances to
references in the textual input.
This makes counting a very cross-modal task,
thus should be solvable only by multimodal
models.
[Ms. Coffee Bean sleeping noises]
We formulate the counting task in a so-called
FOIL setup, by having images with either correct
counting-related captions, or foiled captions,
which are slight, but incorrect modifications
of the original caption.
We generate these examples automatically,
based on the VQA dataset called Visual7W.
We work with an interrogative format, but
also with a declarative one.
The model’s task is to judge whether an
unambiguous question or statement about the
number of entities visible in a natural image,
is correct, or a foil.
We conduct experiments with ViLBERT, ViLBERT
12-in-1 and LXMERT in zero-shot and fine-tuned
settings.
All three models were pre-trained with the
image-sentence alignment task, check this
slide and the paper for more details.
This image-sentence alignment is important
to us, giving us the opportunity to look at
the alignment score assigned by the model,
which reflects the predicted probability that
text and image match.
We use the image-sentence alignment head during
zero-shot testing to tell which ones are correct
or incorrect counting examples and compute
an accuracy score on this binary classification
task.
Results in zero-shot show that the models
cannot solve the counting task.
[oh]
Prominently, ViLBERT has a preference to predict
the correct class, to the detriment of the
foil class.
But we compute also a more permissive score,
the pairwise accuracy ranking,
where for a successful model response, it
is enough if the correct caption ranks higher
in image-sentence-alignment than the foiled
one.
Here we see that ViLBERT 12-in-1 has a better
response.
The result on the declarative format are only
marginally better.
So the poor performance in the zero-shot setting
isn't due to the fact that models trained
on image-sentence alignment could have trouble
with the question-answer format.
In fine-tuning the picture seems to change
to the better, with performances increasing
to even 81%!
[Ms. Coffee Bean]: But does this mean that
these models really count?
No, or so our next experiment on the interpolated
split says, where we finetune on even numbers
and test on odd numbers.
If the models are actually counting, then
this should generalize sufficiently for them
to solve the task in the interpolated case.
But when we do this, Ms. Coffee Bean, the
model’s accuracy drops to random chance.
And we have even more experiments, to underline
the results we got so far with the image-sentence-alignment
head.
So, we have experiments with masked language
modelling, where we let the model replace
the numeral.
The overall accuracy looks quite good at 55%,
but it is just an artefact of the model predicting
the most frequent numerals in training, like
0, 1 and 2, but being unable to go beyond
2.
The same picture is painted by letting the
model answer the question, in VQA.
For all the details, and even more experiments
for this, make sure to check out the paper
linked in the description below!
Therefore, Ms.Coffee Bean...!
... by means of our counting probe, we have
found that vision and language models are
still prone to biases, and seem to learn broken
heuristics that clearly does not generalize
well.
For further investigation, we encourage the
use of our counting probe for diagnosing the
absence of proper cross-modal alignment.
Check out the link to the data on GitHub in
the description below.
Let us know what you think or want to ask
in the comments!
Ms. Coffee Bean, how long have you been awake
now?
Oh, no, so heard the whole thing.
Are you mad on me now?
It’s research on multimodality, it's your
favorite, right?
You are mad, right?
Ah... bye!
Bye!